thaler annie suite du procès d'omar
raddad devant la cour d'assises des
alpes-maritimes je vous rappelle que
l'intéressé est accusé du meurtre de
ghislaine marchal l'héritière du groupe
qui porte le même nom ce matin on n'a
toujours pas aborder les faits c'est la
personnalité de l'accusé qui est
toujours en première ligne
dominique verdeilhan gilles de blair au
fond de la salle d'audience le père et
les pousses de marada tous deux hier
sont venus faire le portrait d'un
jardinier ordinaire celui d'un mari et
d'un fils non violent attentif une vie
heureuse sans histoire jusqu'à ce que
son nom apparaisse dans une cave en
lettres de sang
ce matin le président de géant et
peluches les mouvements bancaires de
l'accusé plus de 80 mille francs retirer
en deux ans c'était pour la famille pour
le pays répond omar le président
n'insiste pas et passe aux mises de
celui qu'il appelle un habitué discret
des casinos le président évoque la
déposition de 25 personnes certaines se
souviennent avoir vu omar raddad devant
des machines à sous agacé par ce procès
d'intention l'accusé s'enflamme on
aurait interrogé 50 ou 100 personnes
cela ne me dérangerait pas oui j'allais
parfois au casino de cannes et ce matin
la justice est prise à son propre piège
saisie d'un dossier sans preuves face à
une énigme dont elle n'a pas réussi à
trouver la clé
la cour d'assises des alpes-maritimes
recherche désespérément une faille dans
la personnalité de marque raddad
pourtant joué n'est ni un crime ni un
délit une justice donc prise à son
propre piège car en faisant le procès
d'un flambeur elle fait aussi
parallèlement celui d'instruction